The tortoise and
the hare are racing
to see who can run 100 feet in
the shortest amount of time.
Their positions in feet as a
function of time in seconds,
T of t and H of t respectively,
are plotted below.
So T of t is the position of the
tortoise as a function of time,
and it's in feet.
H of t is the
position of the hare.
What is the meaning
of the rate of change
of T of t on the interval
t is greater than 0
and less than 20?
So T of t, they were talking
about the tortoise here.
This is the function T
of t right over here,
this blue line.
And it looks like it's moving
at a constant rate of change.
The slope of this
line is constant.
So let's see what this
rate of change is.
If we start-- so
we could even start
from the starting position.
When 1 second goes
by, each notch here
in the horizontal
axis is 1 second.
You see 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
So every time 1 second
goes by, it looks like--
and we have to be
very careful here.
At first it looks like,
oh, maybe he moves 1 feet.
But we have to be careful about
what these notches represent.
It looks like these notches
represent 5, 10, 15, 20,
25 feet.
So every time 1 second goes
by, he moves forward 5 feet.
Another second goes by,
he moves forward 5 feet.
So it looks like the
rate of the tortoise,
so I'll say the
tortoise rate, the rate
of the change of distance
with respect to time
is 5 feet for every second.
So let's see which of our
choices seem to match that.
And that is over
the entire interval.
The interval starts
here, this is 0,
and 20 is right over here.
And it looks like we
have a constant rate,
we have a constant slope.
We have the same
inclination of this line
the entire time all the
way until t is equal to 20.
So this first choice
says the tortoise walks
at 5 feet per second the whole
time, and this looks right.
Our tortoise has a constant
rate of 5 feet per second.
This walks might be
an understatement.
5 feet per second is a
pretty good speed, especially
for a tortoise.
But we are going to
go with that one.
Now, let's just look at
the other ones for fun
to see how true they are
or see if they could have
somehow applied to this problem.
The hare stops moving
after 5 seconds.
So let's see, this is
time 0, this is 5 seconds.
So if we look at the hare's
position after 5 seconds,
so after time
equals 5 seconds, it
does indeed look like the hare's
position-- the hare is just
sitting there at the
90-foot marker line
and is not moving at all.
The rate of change of
position with respect
to time for the hare
at that point is 0.
So this does seem true, it just
doesn't apply to the question.
It's not the meaning
of the rate of change
of T of t on this interval.
This is applying to H of t.
The hare runs at a speed of 18
feet per second for the first 5
seconds.
So let's see if this is true.
For the first 5 seconds, so
this is 5 seconds going by,
the hare is able to cover
a distance of 90 feet.
So the hare is able to
go 90 feet in 5 seconds,
so for the first 5
seconds, the hare
is-- hare's rate is 90 feet.
You could say average rate of
change is 90 feet in 5 seconds.
And 90 divided by 5 is
indeed 18 feet per second.
So once again, this
third statement is true,
it just doesn't apply to T of t.
It's not addressing
the question.
Now this fourth choice is
that the hare wins the race.
Now, winning the
race, they have to get
to 100 feet in the
shortest amount of time.
This is 100 feet
right over here.
So let's see.
So it looks like only
the tortoise even
gets to that point.
At 20 seconds, the tortoise
gets to the 100-foot mark.
The hare is still hanging
around taking a nap or something
at 90 feet.
So this is actually
outright false.
The tortoise wins the race.
So we will definitely go
with our first choice.